yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
as you might have been hoping Captain
America Civil War has to post-credit
scenes one which appears just after the
credits from the main cast and another
after the full set of credits of
finished rolling in this video I'm going
to talk about both those scenes and just
to be clear there are spoilers ahead so
if you want to avoid those you can watch
my spoiler free review right here the
mid credits start with Bucky being
tended to by a doctor in a super
high-tech medical facility and his metal
arm is still missing from when it was
blasted off by Iron Man in the movie we
then see Steve Rogers oh is Bucky and he
asked his friend you sure about this -
which Bucky replies I can't trust my own
mind so until they figure out how to get
this stuff out of my head I think going
back and it's the best thing for
everybody Bucky is then strapped into an
upright cryo chamber and frozen a nod to
the flashback scene in the Winter
Soldier film where Zola orders Bucky to
be put on ice and also a callback to how
he was put in cryostasis by the Russians
and the Captain America comics while
they figured out what to do with him
the camera then cuts to Black Panther
and Captain America Steve Rogers thanks
to Charla who responds your friend and
my father they were both victims if I
can help one of them find peace the
Advanced Medical Center reflects the
fact that in the Marvel Comics work and
is a wealthy and technologically
advanced nation thanks to its vibranium
deposits it looks like the wakandan
doctors and scientists might work on how
to erase the Hydra programming from
Bucky's brain Rogers then warns that if
they find out Heath here they'll come
for him - which black panther responds
let them try the camera then pans away
from the medical center to a view of a
misty jungle location with a waterfall
and mountains in the backgrounds and a
huge black panther statue so this is a
pretty cool tease for the 2018 black
panther solo movie with an intriguing
peek of what work handle looks like in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and with
Marvel Studios president and producer
Kevin Feige saying that the Black
Panther movie has important links to
infinity War part 1 it looks likely
we'll see Bucky brought back for both
those movies and possibly we'll also see
some Avengers or someone else coming off
to Bucky in the Black Panther movie by
the way there's a really cool Easter Egg
to do with Bucky being shut down in the
mid credit sequence the working title of
civil war was actually Sputnik and in
the comics Sputnik is the safe word that
the Russians implanted in Bucky has a
say
50 mechanism to shut him down in case he
went crazy a bit like how the other
winter soldiers in this movie turn
against their guards moving on to the
post credits this scene starts with
Peter Parker in his bedroom with art
made calling in to him and asking who it
was who hit him Peter replies some guy
while he's fiddling with what looks like
his web shooter around his wrist this
dialogue is a callback to the airport
fight scene and when art may asked what
the guy's name is Peter replies Steve in
other words Steve Rogers art may wants
to know if it's Steve from 12 see the
guy with the overbite but Peter says
that he's from Brooklyn which is where
Captain America's from the mention of
12c could be a little Easter Egg - the
price of the first spider-man comic and
the point about the overbite is a funny
callback to Tony Stark tying cap in this
movie that sometimes I want to punch you
in your perfect teeth as Peter's talking
to Aunt May he activates the shooter
which sends a beam of light up onto the
ceiling but he hides it away quickly
when Aunt May comes into the room May
asked him more about the fight and Peter
mentions that Steve's friend is huge a
funny reference to his fight with giant
man at the airport aren't May then
leaves and Peter uncovers his arm and
the camera pans up to reveal a beam
projecting a very cool Spidey symbol
onto the ceiling the film then ends with
the words spider-man will return so this
piece of tech is likely something that
Tony Stark has made or enhanced for
Peter Parker remember we already saw
Tony create an Iron Man glove out of a
high-tech device on his wrist in this
movie and Peter Parker's device is very
much like the spider signal that Peter
Parker has attached to his belt in the
comics by the way given that Tony
Stark's former science bro Bruce Banner
aka The Hulk is currently AWOL I really
like the way that Tony and Peter seem to
be on their way to becoming the new
science Bros with Tony likely having
provided Peter with his new Spidey suit
for the airport fight and with Robert
Downey jr. now confirmed to appear in
spider-man homecoming it's a cool hint
that we can expect more tech geeking out
with Iron Man and spider-man in the 2017
solo movie ok guys that's the mid and
post credits scenes from Captain America
Civil War if you've seen the movie
already do you have any cool theories
about what they might mean for future
MCU movies by the way coming up have
also got a cool giveaway for this
awesome hardback book Captain America
the ultimate guide to the First Avenger
which is packed with tons of cool
info and images about caps 75 year
history and Marvel Comics that's going
to be on my full easter-egg guide for
Civil War so make sure your sub to see
that and if you want to check out more
of my videos on Civil War you can click
here for my full Easter Egg video guide
to the movie and here for my fall Civil
War playlist with my review cast
interviews and lots more if you enjoyed
this don't forget to subscribe share and
like
thanks for watching and see you next
time here we go a movie lovers